Magnus Carlson suffered an astonishing
upset against a player rated over 300
points less than him then took to
Twitter to raise concerns about a lack
of fair play protection specifically he
said he was distracted by his opponent's
watch while he didn't make any
accusations he claimed the organizers
weren't taking anti-cheating measures
seriously enough magnus's distractions
aside his opponent Grandmaster alisher
sulov played a brilliant game with 96.8%
accuracy and two brilliancies in this
position alisher sacrificed his Knight
on F7 quickly followed by an exchange
sack on D5 alliser's devastating attack
continued and a few moves later Magnus
resigned Magnus hasn't lost to a player
below 2550 since he was a teenager in